you and me hosting the spirit awards huh
nick i'm actually feeling a little
nervous why why honey what's going on i
don't know i don't know i just i think i
just i need a confidence boost again
oh my god
hey
sorry to bother you guys just dropping
off some water and snacks oh great yeah
thank you so much
thank you i feel right i feel ready just
one more thing wait a minute sarah
hey the hell are you doing here doing in
that box hey guys i'm the backup host
it's a liability thing since you both
joined twitter before 2015 it's standard
procedure for us to keep a backup post
in case anything resurfaces before
showtime could happen yeah just act like
i'm not even here all right okay oh you
want to run through some of our
monologue jokes yeah sounds good hit me
okay great
oh my god this is one of my favorites
come on come on is nominated for best
feature
it's also nominated for phrase most
frequently said in our bedrooms
[Music]
[Laughter]
did you want to chime in sarah oh no no
i guess um i don't know i just a sex
joke from a heteronormative couple in
2022 it's just kind of like i don't know
i feel like it's going to come across
like you're perverted
these are serious people you guys you
know they like comedy that mean
something to stand for something you
know like maybe something like and i'm
just pitching here um
come on come on is nominated for best
feature stop fracking now that's it what
that's not even a joke oh i'm sorry i
didn't know you two loved fracking
we don't love you we don't love fracking
what are you getting checks from
monsanto or something monsanto franking
is the
the one thing monsanto doesn't do yeah i
wouldn't know because i'm not on their
board chill out erin brockovich okay i
mean this is me and nick i'm just
looking out for you guys like i'm
telling you you've gotta go political
it's the only reason people watch award
shows sorry but
forgive us if we don't want to take
advice from someone who's stuck in an
airtight storage container
if this was an airtight storage
container i wouldn't be able to breathe
[Music]
you know one of those things where you
can kind of circle in like in spy movies
like a spy
what should we do i have my cordless
drill and my diamond bits but they're in
my other pants should i go get them no
nick we're gonna go out there and we're
gonna host the best damn awards show
that anyone ever hosted we'll do it for
sarah
you're right
it's what she would have wanted i want
to live
did you hear that honey
she wants to
laugh
comedian to the very end yep
let's go out there and host the frack
out of this show we'll do it for sarah
silverman
gone too soon
for sarah silverman
you